[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग दोस्तों एक बार सब
मेरे को यह बता दीजिए सबको आवाज ए रही है
ओके थैंक यू
आप सभी का स्वागत है युटुब चैनल पर फिर से
तो आज फिर हम कंटिन्यू करने वाले हैं की
जो कुछ ट्रिक बैक गई थी
उन पर कंटिन्यू करने वाले हैं उसके बाद हम
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक पर चलेंगे क्योंकि ट्विटर
को काफी लंबा हमने
ट्विटर अपने आप में अगर उसके ट्रिक के
बेसिस पे जाए तो काफी लंबा है भी अपने आप
में टोपी और आई अब मैं समझना हूं आप लोगों
को क्योंकि कंटिन्यू देखना और प्रैक्टिकल
ना कर पन आप लोगों के लिए प्रॉब्लम है ठीक
है और आप लोग अरबी नहीं का रहे हो अगर
देखो अगर आप लोगों को टारगेट चीज करना तो
क्राउड या हैकर वन से टारगेट कर सकते
क्योंकि वहां पर प्रोग्राम चलते हैं तो
वहां पर क्या करोगे वहां पर इन सब कुछ
करके वहां पर क्या कर सकते हैं साड़ी
इनफॉरमेशन
परफॉर्म कर सकते हो
आई अंडरस्टैंड की आप लोग बोलोगे तो डोंट
वारी सोशल मीडिया जो अपना वाला टॉपिक है
इसको जैसे फिनिश कर देंगे हम जैसे ही
फेसबुक इंस्टा वाला फिनिश कर देंगे
हम तुरंत बाद क्या है कुछ लैप्स सॉल्व
करेंगे काफी इंटरेस्टिंग है और मीडियम
लेवल की लैब से ऐसे नहीं की इजी लैब है तो
वो सॉल्व करेंगे तो आप लोगों को
रियलिस्टिक थोड़ा सा और मजा आएगा की बोलो
हां चीज कैसे हो रही है क्योंकि वो इतनी
ज्यादा डिटेल में उनके ओपन सोशल एजेंट
करना नहीं वो लेकिन क्या है की आपको
आइडिया मिल जाएगा आपको एक
बात मिल जाएगा एक दे मिल जाएगी आपको कैसे
क्या करना है की कैसे आगे बढ़ाना है आपको
कैसे चीजों को समझना होता है
चलो फिर हम स्टार्ट करते हैं आप लोगों को
पता है की कंटिन्यू करते हैं कोई मुझे
बताया लास्ट जो सेशन में प्रेजेंट था की
लास्ट ट्रिक क्या थी हमारी जो हमने सिख की
थी
बताना
प्लास्टिक बनाना
ट्रिक नंबर या जो भी ट्रिक थी अगर किसी को
याद है तो प्लीज
ट्रिक नंबर
नाइंटील वाली चीजों के बड़े में
स्पेसिफिक के बड़े में हमने आपको बताया था
चलो फिर कंटिन्यू करते हैं ट्रिक नंबर है
आपकी
लेंथ उसके साथ उसे करते हैं ट्रिक में और
उसके बाद क्या यहां पर हम मेंशन करते हैं
इंग्लिश के लिए या पर एग्जांपल अगर हमें
किसके लिए zn4 स हा पर चाइनीस के लिए ऐसे
तो यहां पर हम मेंशन करते हैं किस
लैंग्वेज में अब मैं आपको एग्जांपल देखो
अगर आपको पहले से पता की जो आपका टारगेट
है वो कौन सी लैंग्वेज बोलना है की पर
एग्जांपल मैक्सिमम टारगेट्स के क्या है
इंग्लिश में सक्सेसफुल मिलेंगे इंग्लिश
बोलते हुए मिलेंगे अब वो तो आम लैंग्वेज
है आम में इतना आसन नहीं है इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग करना तो अगर आपको इसका आइडिया है
की आपका टारगेट कौन सी लैंग्वेज बोल सकता
है आइडिया कैसे मिलेगा आपको उसकी जो पोस्ट
है उसकी ट्वीट्स है वो पढ़ के आपको आइडिया
मिलेगा
जैसे की अब यहां पर आम लैंग्वेज की बात
कारी हो सकता है की आपके टारगेट्स को
मल्टीप्लेक्स लैंग्वेज आई हो हिंदी हिंदी
भी आई है उर्दू भी आई हो फ्रेंच भी आई हो
चाइनीस भी आता है वॅटीवर कोई भी लैंग्वेज
आई हो जापानी कोई भी लैंग्वेज आई है हो
सकता है चांसेस है क्योंकि देखो एक कोई भी
कंपनी है कोई भी एक ऑपरेट कंपनी होती है
वो ओनली एक जगह तो होती नहीं है वो
मल्टीप्लेक्स कंट्रीज में भी कम करती है
तो उसके बाद सीधी सी बात है उसके
मल्टीप्लेक्स कंट्री से क्लाइंट्स भी
होंगे एम्पलाई भी होंगे जब अपने लिए अगर
मल्टी कॉरपोरेट कंपनी है तो काफी बड़ी
कंपनी है तो अगर उसके फोन क्लाइंट होंगे
तो इसका मतलब क्या की फोन फोन क्लाइंट से
टॉप करने के लिए बात करने के लिए ठीक है
इंग्लिश आम भी है बट क्या हो सकता है की
आपके जो इसको हमने टारगेट किया है वो आपका
टारगेट ऐसा है की उसको मल्टीप्लेक्स
लैंग्वेज आई है तो अगर उसको पर क्लाइंट्स
फोन क्लाइंट्स से अगर उसको क्या करना है
बात करनी होगी या ट्वीट करना होगा तो क्या
करेगा वो इस लैंग्वेज में प्रेफर करेगा
भाई वो उसे लैंग्वेज में मास्टर ना हो वो
लैंग्वेज उसको कंप्लीट नहीं आई वो लेकिन
उसको खैर उसको थोड़ा बहुत आइडिया है
तब भी है तो उसके अपने ट्वीट के थ्रू ये
पता करने में आपको आपके जो टारगेट है उसको
इंग्लिश के अलावा पर एग्जांपल चाइनीस
लैंग्वेज भी आई है पर एग्जांपल ले रहा हूं
तो फिर आप क्या कर सकते हो उससे लैंग्वेज
स्पेसिफिक ट्रिक का उसे करके आप क्या कर
सकते हो ये भी पता कर सकते हो क्या आपके
टारगेट को चाइनीस लैंग्वेज आई है तो क्या
कोई ट्वीट हुआ है इससे इस लैंग्वेज के
थ्रू तो आप उसे पर्टिकुलर ट्वीट किया तो
जा सकते हो जिससे क्या क्या है की आप ये
कंफर्म कर पाओगे की हां जो आपके जो आपका
टारगेट है या जो आपकी जो कंपनी टारगेट
कंपनी है तो उसके क्या है फोन क्लाइंट भी
है दूसरा क्या है की अगर आपका जो टारगेट
है वो दूसरी लैंग्वेज में बात कर का रहा
है पर एग्जांपल मैं जो चाइनीस लैंग्वेज की
बात की है अगर उसे लैंग्वेज में बात कर का
रहा है तो हम सिंपल सा मतलब है की उसमें
ट्वीट किया है तो इसका मतलब क्या है की
उसके कल उसका जो है
दोस्त है वो फॉरेनर्स भी है मतलब की और
नर्स भी उसके फ्रेंड है और वहां भी क्या
है आपको उसके बेसिस पे क्या कर सकते हो आप
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हो हो सकता है
कुछ ऐसी ट्वीट हो उनके बीच में जो
उन्होंने ट्वीट किया है या अच्छे दोस्त
हैं तो आप क्या कर सकते हो ठीक है आपका
टारगेट कंप्रोमाइज नहीं होता फॉरेनर दोस्त
आपका कंप्रोमाइज हो सकता है तो आप उसको
फिर सोशल इंजीनियरिंग से उसको कंप्रोमाइज
करने की कोशिश करोगे थोड़ा सा और
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कोशिश करोगे जो हो सकता
है जो आपके टारगेट के बड़े में
ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन आपको प्रोवाइड कर दे तो
इस ट्रिक को हम कैसे उसे करेंगे पर
एग्जांपल ये मेरा
ये मेरा इंस्टाग्राम पेज है अब मैं फाइंड
आउट करना चाहता हूं मैं सच बाहर है सर्च
बार में मैं क्या करता हूं मैं टारगेट का
नाम रखना हूं मैं यही मेरा टारगेट का नाम
आप सबको पता है मैं यहां से उठाता हूं
एग्जांपल लिया था
मैंने और एवं मैंने क्या कर दिया यहां पर
कंट्रोल
ये कोड मुझे कैसे पता चलेगा
गवर्नमेंट वेबसाइट
यहां पर देखिए यह होता है
www.loc.gov.in
अगर किसी को भी लेना है तो मैं आपको 1
मिनट का टाइम दे रहा हूं तो यहां पर क्या
है ना आपको या ईर्ष्या मतलब यहां पर सर वो
चीज मेंशन है ये लैंग्वेज के अकॉर्डिंग जो
कोड है ना आइसो कोड है उसको आप उसे कर
सकते हो पर एग्जांपल इंग्लिश के लिए ए एन
जैसे की ये रहा चाइनीस के लिए इसके लिए पर
एग्जांपल जैसे की मुझे अभी देखते हैं
बंगाली के लिए हम बा न्यूज़ करेंगे बंगाली
उसे करेंगे
वाला उसे करेंगे
उसे और उसके बाद क्या है हमे क देखो ch4
पता करना
और मैं अपने इसमें क्या करूंगा
की आप लोगों को पता चल जाएगी ये वो
वेबसाइट है
स्क्रीनशॉट
चलो फिर एक कम करते हैं
[संगीत]
जो आपका टारगेट्स है वो चाइनीस लैंग्वेज
बोल सकता है क्योंकि उन्होंने क्या है की
चाइनीस लैंग्वेज में भी देखो रिप्लाई किया
हो
कुछ पोस्ट ऐसी है जो लैंग्वेज चाइनीस है
ओके बोल सकता नहीं बोल सकता बट देखिए
टेनिस रेसिपी है मतलब यहां पर क्या है
इसको क्या किया उसे किया गया है इनकी
पोस्टमैन ये रहा ओके रिप्लाई तू नो नो नो
ये क्या फाइंड आउट कर दिया उसने
ओके मतलब की जो चाइनीस पार्टनर आपका उसने
क्या किया है इनको भी क्या किया है ट्वीट
किया हुआ है तो इसलिए क्या है यहां पर
मेंशन 10 अगर में वो मेंशन साइड है इसलिए
आप आपको देखने को ये देखने को मिल रहा है
बट भी कान सर की ये बोलते नहीं बोलते हैं
बट क्या है की हम इसे बेसिस पे क्या कर
सकते हैं अपना फिल्टर आउट कर सकते हो तो
ये है लैंग्वेज स्पेसिफिक ट्रिक तो आज हम
थोड़ा जल्दी-जल्दी चलते हैं क्योंकि काफी
लंबा बच्चा हुआ है तो देखिए ये है
लैंग्वेज स्पेसिफिक यहां इंग्लिश चाइनीस
वॅटीवर लैंग्वेज आप क्या कर सकते हैं आपको
चीज कर सकते हो और यहां पर इंडियन है तो
हम हिंदी भी उसे कर सकते हैं तो इसके लिए
हम क्या करेंगे और हिंदी के लिए क्या उसे
है
कंट्रोल अप करते हैं यहां पर एक बार
उसे करेंगे
हिंदी में ही बात हो राखी है देखिए यहां
पर है कुछ है जो आपको देखने को मिल रहे
हैं किसी ने इनको रेफर किया है या कुछ
अपने कंप्लेन दिया है कुछ भी है तो यहां
पे आपको कुछ ना कुछ देखने को मिलेगा
ट्रिक नंबर 11
1111 में क्या करोगे
[संगीत]
उससे पहले उसके बाद क्या करते हैं हम
जिओ कोड जिओ कोड लिखेंगे यहां पर उसके बाद
यहां पर लिख देंगे हम लट्टीट्यूड ल ए टी
आई टी यू दी लट्टीट्यूड उसके पास लिखने
हैं हम लोंगिट्यूड ल ओ एन एन जी आई टी यू
दी लोंगिट्यूड उसके बाद हम यहां पर
मोमेंटम रेडियस रेडियस 5 किलोमीटर 10
किलोमीटर जो भी है मैंने लिखा फाइव किमी
लाइक डेट अब लट्टीट्यूड क्या होता है
नॉर्थ साउथ ज्योग्राफिकल कोऑर्डिनेट्स
होता जो लट्टीट्यूड होता है आपका उसको हम
बोलते हैं नॉर्थ साउथ
[संगीत]
ऑर्डिनेंस
होते हैं नेक्स्ट
लोंगिट्यूड क्या होता है लोंगिट्यूड होता
है
आपने अगर कोई एड्रेस मिला आपको इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग के दौरान अगर कोई एड्रेस मिला तो
एड्रेस में क्या हो सकता है
कोऑर्डिनेटर फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो
जहां पर क्या की आपको हो सकता है इस एरिया
में आपका टारगेट हो सकता है तो आप गूगल
मैप पर जाओगे वहां से क्या करोगे
लट्टीट्यूड लोंगिट्यूड कॉपी करोगे
दिल्ली दिल्ली दिल्ली दिल्ली दिल्ली
दिल्ली दिल्ली
एरिया स्पेसिफिक मुझे मिल रहा है मुझे ऐसा
कुछ मिल रहा है की इधर आपका टारगेट हो
सकता है कहानी ना कहानी आपको रोल बार बट
जो भी आपको देखने को मिला मैंने यहां पर
क्या किया क्लिक करूंगा राइट क्लिक करूंगा
मैं यहां पर और उसके क्या करता हूं
लोंगिट्यूड लूंगा अब मैं क्या करना चाहता
हूं की मैं साइट ट्वीट देखना चाहता हूं इस
एरिया के तो मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पर एक
सर्किल टाइप का म्यूजिक कर लो मजे एक लेडी
है इसके जो 5 किलोमीटर के एरिया में जितनी
भी ट्वीट्स हुई होगी उसकी वेट से लेते हैं
सारे के सारे क्या करूंगा फाइंड आउट करना
चाहता हूं अब मैं क्या करूंगा पहले तो
मेरे पास क्या एक नाम के अकॉर्डिंग मैं
एरिया के नाम के अकॉर्डिंग
इस एरिया के मैं फिर एक पेरीमीटर बना रहा
हूं पेरीमीटर में ही हूं काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
चीज है तो ये मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं पर
एग्जांपल मैं अभी क्या करता हूं की मेरे
पास अगर कोई भी टारगेट टारगेट क्या करने
पर
कुछ भी नहीं है तो एड्रेस में आपको
एग्जांपल ले सकते हैं हम अब आपको एक और
चीज बताता हूं आपको की अगर आपको क्या है
की जो आपका पी कोड होता है पी कोड के
बेसिस पे लोंगिट्यूड लट्टीट्यूड
लट्टीट्यूड अगर आपको फाइंड आउट करने हैं
तो वो कैसे करोगे तो वो मैं आपको बताता
हूं एक वेबसाइट होती है कौन सी जिओ कोड
जिओ कोड डॉट एक्स ए स होती है एक्स
ए स एक्स ए स
ओके
ये वो वेबसाइट
कोई भी पी कोड ले सकते हैं हम यहां पर
वैसे देखो ये कोऑर्डिनेट्स तो शो कर किसके
शो कर रहा है
एक मिनट कोई भी पी कोड कोई भी बता सकता है
जिसको हम क्या कर सकते हैं एक एरिया में
कैसा था एनिमल मुझे कोई पी कोड याद है तो
नहीं ए रहा तो अगर किसी को कोई भी चाट में
बता सकता है जिसको हम क्या कर सकते हैं
यहां पर आपके सामने मैं देखा सकता हूं ये
कैसे कम करता है यहां पर क्या कोई भी पी
कोड दे सकते हो आप तो आपको पता चल जाएगा
अन्योन कोई भी पी कोड बनाना चाहता है
कोई भी चाट में बता सकता है
को-ऑर्डिनेटर
[संगीत]
एक कम कर देंगे कोई विदाउट कीबोर्ड
हम क्या करते हैं जिओ कोड करते पहले
लिटिट्यूड लोंगिट्यूड करना है कंट्रोल बी
मैंने लट्टीट्यूड और लोंगिट्यूड यहां पर
लिख दिया जिओ कोड उसके बेस पर मैं क्या कर
रहा हूं दें जिओ को लेटर तू लोंगिट्यूड
दें कॉम फिर मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं ओनली
30 किलोमीटर 30 किलोमीटर 30 कि मैंने कर
दिया
एक कम करते हैं हमारे पास सबसे बेस्ट
ऑप्शन क्या नाम है गूगल
नेट करते हैं
यहां पर क्या करते हैं
चलते हैं और चलो
कोई भी केवल
इनफॉरमेशन तो है नहीं क्योंकि इनफॉरमेशन
इतना टाइम मेरे पास तो नहीं है की मुझको
अलग से सर्च आउट कर पता तो यहां पर क्या
के शब्द डॉग कीवर्ड के बाद जिओ कोड जिओ
कोड के बाद लिटिट्यूड और लोंगिट्यूड उसके
बाद आप क्या करते हो रेडियस मेंशन का तो
हो सकता है की इससे क्या कर सकते हो आप
क्या है ना अपने आप जो आपको अगर आपका
टारगेट के बड़े में आपको लोकेशन के बड़े
में थोड़ा सा आइडिया है अब क्या कर सकते
हो ट्वीट्स के बेस में आप नेहरू डॉ कर
सकते हो आप एक सर्किल बना कर सकते हो की
इस एरिया में ही आपका टारगेट हो सकता है
इसी एरिया से ही आपकी में ट्वीट निकली हुई
है
तो आप ऐसे कर सकते हैं तो
[संगीत]
कम करेंगे
और इसमें एक मिनट एक मिनट हम लोग क्या वह
वेबसाइट थी हमारी एक कम करते हैं
मुंबई
पेटीएम
उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं
जिओ कोड उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं
नेक्स्ट और कंट्रोल भी उसके बाद हम क्या
करें
इस तरीके से क्या का सकते हो आप अपने
रिजल्ट को वोट भी ज्यादा नैरो डॉ कर सकते
हैं ओके तो यह ट्रिक नंबर आपकी 11 और बात
करते हैं ट्रिक नंबर 12 पे चलते हैं एक
नंबर
ट्रिक नंबर 12 शायद ये नहीं नहीं वो ट्रिक
नहीं है हमारी ओके ट्रिक नहीं है बस हो
गया हो गया हो गया यही थे मी ड्रीम टेक एक
बार आप सबको पता चल गया की ट्रिक एक नंबर
वन तू थ्री फोर फाइव सेवन आते नाइन तक मैं
बता चुका था 10 में बता देता हूं की आप
लैंग्वेज स्पेसिफिक फिल्टर लगा के आप क्या
कर सकते हो पर्टिकुलर पोस्ट को फाइंड आउट
कर सकते हो और आप 11 का उसे तो काफी अच्छे
से उसे कर सकते हो अगर आपको पता है की अगर
आपके पास एग्जैक्ट कीवर्ड आपके पास पता है
इनफॉरमेशन क्लोजिंग गैदरिंग के दौरान आपको
पता है की ये के शब्द उसे किया हो गए
क्योंकि या तो कोई इवेंट चल रहा होगा या
कोई हॉट इशू चल रहा होगा और आपको आपके पास
लोकेशन का आइडिया की इस लोकेशंस में आपका
टारगेट राहत होगा और इसी लोकेशन ट्वीट हुए
होंगे तो आप क्या कर सकते हो एक पेरीमीटर
टाइप बना के क्या कर सकते हो वहां से
लिटिट्यूड लोंगिट्यूड लेकर आपके रेडियस
डिफाइन करके लेक आप क्या कर सकते हो आप वह
कम करती है आप रेंज पेसिफिक मैप पर जाइए
उसको जूम करके आप क्या कर सकते हो
कोऑर्डिनेट्स निकाल सकते हो पता नहीं पी
कोड स्पेसिफिक किसने कम क्यों नहीं किया
वही बट क्या की वही एक वेबसाइट थी जो आपके
इनको डिनर को अच्छे से निकाल पाती है तो
अब ये क्या लट्टीट्यूड लोंगिट्यूड और
कोऑर्डिनेट्स सॉरी उसके बाद आप पैरामीटर
डिफाइन करोगे तो आप क्या कर सकते हो अपने
जड़ को नए डॉ कर सकते हो और उसे रेंज को
क्या-क्या पहले 100 किमी का काफी 50 रखो
फिर 30 करो तो आपको पता चल जाएगा की 30
में कुछ नहीं ए रहा लेकिन 50 ए रहा है
इसका मतलब क्या है की 50 किलोमीटर का दिया
मैं एरिया में 30 में ए गया तो इसका मतलब
आप हर बार क्या कर रहे हो आपने मुझे
टारगेट किया आसपास पहुंच रहे हो और टाइगर
स्पेसिंग मतलब आप क्या डिफाइन कर पाओगी
यही वो एरिया है जी एरिया के अंदर से
एक्टिवेट हुए हैं जैसे मैं आपका टारगेट
किया करता है राहत होगा या उसके कोई
कस्टमर हैं एम्पलाई हैं पार्टनर्स हैं
क्योंकि कहानी ना कहानी तो मोबाइल कर रहे
हैं ना तो वो सारे यहां से एक प्रकार से
आप ट्रैक वाला कम कर सकते हो तो ये था
आपका वो 11 ट्रिक जो आपको ट्विटर के बड़े
में पता हनी चाहिए अब एक चीज बताता हूं
आपको की इंटरेस्ट को आप कंबाइन भी कर सकते
हो इन ट्रिक को आप कंबाइन भी कर सकते हो
कैसे कर सकते हो इन ट्रिक आपस में कंबाइन
करने के लिए पर एग्जांपल मैं कंबाइन कैसे
कर सकता हूं ट्रिक को
ये रहा देखो कंबाइन करने के लिए सिंपली
क्या है की कंबाइन करने का आपका सबसे
सिंपल मोटर ये होता है की आप आपको पता है
की आपने एक अच्छी खासी इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग
कर ली है उसके बाद क्या करूं आप अपने
रिजल्ट को वेरीफाई कर रहे हो या एक्यूरेट
रिजल्ट फाइंड आउट करने का कोशिश करो इसमें
आप क्या मल्टी मल्टीपल वृक्ष को एक साथ
उसे करना चाहते हो तो अगर आप मल्टीपल
टिप्स को ट्रिक को एक साथ उसे करना था
उसके लिए आपका करना पड़ेगा किसी भी ट्रिक
को अगर डिफाइन करने के लिए आपको क्या करना
है मतलब बैलेंस इसके अंदर वो ट्रिक डिफाइन
करनी है तो इसमें मैंने क्या किया हमने
टारगेट का नाम रखा मैंने परिंदेंस ने अपने
टारगेट का मैंने क्या रखा है नाम रखा पर
एग्जांपल मैं टारगेट का नाम है ये रहा
आपका नाम है ये
रखा मैंने टारगेट का नाम ओके कॉपी किया
यहां पर
सिंगल उसे करता हूं की अभी वो सिंगल वाला
ही कम कर रहा है
₹35 बार क्या होता है की आप नॉर्मल आपने
टारगेट के बड़े में क्या कर रहे हो फाइंड
आउट करने की कोशिश कर रहे हो तो आपके
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग नहीं हो पाती कई बार
कुछ इनफॉरमेशन आपके सामने नहीं ए पाती
लेकिन अभी क्या किया आपने जो 35 का उसे
करके आपने इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग उसे करने को
उससे हो सकता है कुछ और ज्यादा रिजल्ट
आपको देखने को मिले अब उसके बाद आपको क्या
करना है और भी ट्रिक को उसके साथ क्या
करना है कंबाइन करना है और भी ट्रिक को
क्या करना है आपको कंबाइन करना है तो कैसे
करोगे उसके लिए मैंने क्या किया स्पेस
दिया उसके बाद फिर से अब के वहां क्या है
मैं @ पेटीएम
पेटीएम कीवर्ड होना चाहिए ओके पेटीएम
क्यों होना चाहिए
पेटीएम एक मिनट
@ पेटीएम नहीं कर रहा मैं ओनली पेटीएम
इसके अंदर देने के लिए नेक्स्ट आपने मैंने
क्या किया मुझे पोस्ट फाइंड आउट करनी है
साइंस मैं क्या कहना चाहता हूं पोस्ट
फाइंड आउट करनी है
से लेकर कब अंटील
अंटील कौन सी देखना चाहता हूं
20019 से लेकर
में एड करना चाहता हूं पर एग्जांपल
एक्यूरेट रिजल्ट आपको जुलाई 12 2019 में
पेटीएम उसे किया गया है जहां जहां पेटीएम
की बड़ी उसे किया गया वो साड़ी पिग्स आपके
सामने ए जाएंगे देखिए यहां पर दिस इसे मी
पेटीएम जून मंथ्स स्टेटमेंट चेक
डी 164 आरएस विद यू चार्ज मी डी सभी को
उसने की पेटीएम किया हुआ है फिर ये देखो
साड़ी चीज आपको देखने को मिलता है इस
तरीके से क्या कर सकता है मल्टीप्लेक्स को
एक साथ उसे कर सकते हो इस तरीके से आप
क्या कर सकते हो मल्टीपल टूरिस्ट को एक
साथ उसे कर सकते हो आप क्या कर सकते हो
मैंने क्या किया तो मैं इसके कम कर दिया
नोट्स में लिख देता हूं और भी क्लियर हो
जाएगा 1 मिनट
रुको भैया चलो
मैंने अभी किया था इस तरीके से मैंने किया
मल्टीप्लेक्स को अगर एक साथ उसे करना तो
आप ऐसे मल्टीप्लेक्स को उसे कर सकते हो ये
क्या है
ओके आपको देख रहा होगा यह एक वन तू थ्री
एग्जांपल ये भी एड कर सकते हैं जिओ कोड भी
हमें इसके अंदर एड कर सकता हूं अगर मैं ये
एड करना चाहता हूं तो ये भी कर सकता हूं
कैसे 35 करूंगा मैं यह क्या करेगा
उनके बेसिस पे आप एक कम को अपना रिजल्ट
फाइंड आउट करो जो भी मैंने आपको कम करने
के लिए बोला और मेरे को क्या करो इन सब का
कंबाइन रिजल्ट बना और उसको क्या करो मेरे
स्क्रीन पर शो कर दो मेरे आउटपुट में शो
कर दो या मेरे को प्रिंट करके दे दो तो अब
ये क्या करेगा इन कर से पांच समीकरण के
पहले सर्च करें सर्च करके इनका कंबाइन जो
रिजल्ट्स है आपके सामने शो कर देगा इसलिए
आपको ज्यादा एक्यूरेट देखने को मिलता है
तो ये था आपका ट्विटर ट्विटर ओपन सोशल
टेलीग्राम तो एक बार मुझे ये बता दीजिए
सबको समझ में आया नहीं आया सबको अभी तक
ट्विटर ओपन जितना भी मैंने करवाया किसी को
कुछ डाउट लगता है या कुछ ऐसा लगता है की
बर हो गए या समझ नहीं आया तो प्लीज आप लोग
बता सकते हैं मेरे को अभी
तो आपको मैं एक-दो टूल और बताता हूं वो
देखो आपको प्रैक्टिस करनी होगी एक और चीज
होती है देखो एक चीज होती है
हमारे पास अभी मैं एक कम करता हूं तो कट
कर देता हूं
एक तो है आपका
वन मिलियन वन मिलियन विथ
डॉट मैप
वन मिलियन ट्विटर
एक ऐसा एप्लीकेशन
की इसमें क्या होता है की ये क्या करता है
आपको लास्ट 24 हॉर्स में जी भी लोकेशन से
जितने भी ट्वीट किया गए हैं उसको क्या कर
देता है आपको इस यहां पर एक मैप के तोर पर
काउंटिंग के साथ रिप्रेजेंट कर देता आप
एग्जैक्ट लोकेशन के साथ आता है गली कौन सी
कहां पर है लेकिन यहां पर क्या कंडीशन है
कंडीशन ये है की ये तो ऊपर से एक तो ये
क्या है की टाइम स्पेसिफिक है लास्ट 24
हॉर्स की दूसरा क्या है की इसमें अगर यहां
पर ये है लोकेशन से इस की मिलेगी जिसने
आपके ट्विटर को लोकेशन एक्सेस दिया होगा
इन्हें लोकेशन एक्सेस इनेबल किया हुआ
ट्वीट के साथ बेसिकली क्या किया अगर यूजर
नाम बाय मिस्टेक करते हैं वक्त या पहले
आपने ट्विटर को परमिशन दे रखें हुए की आप
मेरे जो ट्वीट कर सकते हो या मेरे अपने जो
ट्विटर एप्लीकेशन है वह क्या कर सकते हो
आप उसको लोकेशन एक्सेस कर सकते हो क्योंकि
आपका जो ट्विटर है वो इससे मैप से मैप से
तो जुड़ा हुआ है गूगल मैप से तो जुड़ा हुआ
है तो आप क्या कर सकते हो आप मेल लोकेशन
एक्सेस कर सकते हो अगर ऐसी कोई परमिशन दी
हुई है आपके टारगेट नहीं तो आप क्या कर
सकते हो जब भी आपका टारगेट नहीं या कोई
पोस्ट लोकेशन के साथ डाली हुई है तो उसके
बेसिस पे क्या हो सकता है की आपका जो
पोस्ट के आधार पर आपका कर सकते हो अच्छे
एक्यूरेट एनालिसिस कर सकते हो आप किसी भी
पोस्ट के बड़े में तो यहां पर क्या कर
सकते हो आप के शब्द भी दे सकते हो हैशटैग
भी दे सकते हो और यूजर नाम भी दे सकते हो
पर एग्जांपल मैं एक कम करता हूं यहां पर @
पेटीएम करता हूं
जितनी भी ट्वीट हुई होगी उनको क्या कर
देगा
मैं यहां पर देखते चलो
अब यहां पर क्या यह रहा लुधियाना
फरवरी
शो करता है बट क्या है की ये अपडेट हो रहा
था रियल टाइम अपडेट होता है बट यहां पर
क्या है की ये वो भी पोर्ट दिखाकर लास्ट
24 हॉर्स की पोस्ट नहीं है तो प्राणी कोई
भी पोस्ट दिखा दे रहा है जब इसने उसे
लोकेशन को कैप्चर किया होगा अब यार देवर
इस नो गारंटी की उतार के यहां पर अवेलेबल
है या नहीं है क्योंकि आपके जो
क्या बोल सकते हैं जो टारगेट है उसने उसको
एक्सेस दिया है नहीं है लास्ट 24 हॉर्स का
मतलब लोकेशन दिया है तो ये क्या है की
यहां पर दो कंडीशन मेन करते हैं तो कंडीशन
ये है की 24 होना चाहिए या उससे फिर ये
कभी भी कोई रेंडम टीवी दिखाएगा जो भी इस
पर पड़ा हुआ है जब वो लोकेशन एक्सेस के
साथ ट्वीट किया गया होगा अब विदाउट लोकेशन
एक्सेस या लास्ट 24 हाउस मैं अपने तार
क्या है कोई ट्वीट नहीं अगर ट्वीट किया भी
है अगर आप टारगेट आपको सिक्योरिटी
अवेयरनेस एवर्ड है उसको अवेयरनेस है उसको
पता है की मुझे ट्विटर को लोकेशन एक्सेस
प्रोवाइड नहीं करना है तो आप क्या कर सकते
उसको इस अप के थ्रू क्या कर सकते हो
आईडेंटिफाई नहीं कर सकता अब यहां पर दो
टीवी देखने को मिल रही है जैसे पर
एग्जांपल यहां देखते हैं यहां पर कौन सी
है
जितने पेटीएम के उसने क्या कर दिया बैंड
कर दिया होगा तो अब यह ट्वीट दिखा रहा है
तो यह एक काफी अभी तक की यह अप अभी तक
जितने भी क्या है की मैंने
पढ़ने वक्त
काफी कुछ एप्स के नाम से लेकिन कम भी नहीं
करनी है
अगर आप क्या मैन्युअल तरीका अपनाओगे ना
मैन्युअल के टाइम मिलेगा लेकिन आप अच्छा
एनालिसिस कर पाओगे अगर जल्दी के चक्कर में
जाओगे फास्ट पॉजिटिव भी मिल सकता है
कुछ एप्स कम ही नहीं करते ये भी
एक यह अप है जिसके अब यह देखो
टाइमिंग थोड़ा बहुत डिफरेंस है बट क्या है
ए 143 14
एक्सटेंशन है एक एक्सटेंशन आपका जो आप उसे
कर सकते हो जी क्षेत्र का नाम है 1 मिनट
कौन सा गया
[संगीत]
करना है
मेरे को आपको क्या करना है
और यहां पर क्या करना है आपको सर्च करना
है ये रहा
हूं आर डबल आई डबल
एक्शन से देखने को मिल जाएगा
मैंने ऑन भी है तो इसको क्या करता हूं चलो
आपको क्या करना है रन इन प्राइवेट विंडो
आलो कर देना रनिंग प्राइवेट विंडो आपको
क्या कर देना है अलाओ कर देना है चलो एक
कम करते हैं फिर ये भी अपना कम चल रहा है
और ये
नोट रिपोर्ट चलो
एक्सटेंशन अपना कम कर रहा है
हम चलते हैं अपने ट्वीट्स के ऊपर जितनी भी
ट्वीट्स हो गई होगी और हम क्या करते हैं
टारगेट मेरा क्या है टारगेट टारगेट किया
था
तो यहां पर
एक्सटेंशन आप उसे करोगे तो यहां पर एक जो
क्या करता हूं जब भी आप क्या करते हो चलो
चलो एक कम करता हूं 1 मिनट
ये रहा ओके ओके इट्स वर्किंग इट्स वर्किंग
आप किसी भी पोस्ट पर क्लिक करोगे उसके बाद
यहां पर ऑटोमेटेकली आईकॉन आपको देखने को
मिलेगा रिवर्स का आप यहां पर क्लिक करोगे
रिवर्स का यहां पर जैसे क्लिक करोगे आप
देखने को मिलेगा काफी ये एक इमेज टाइप का
आपको क्रिएट करके दिखा देगा यहां एक मिनट
एक मिनट
बहुत हैंग कर रही है यार
लोडिंग करना है काफी टाइम मिलेगा
आप उसे करके देखिए अगर नहीं चला तो बताना
मेरे को ठीक है
अब ये देखना ट्विटर भी मेरा कम बहुत स्लो
कर रहा है तो यह था आपका ट्विटर के दो कुछ
एक अप थी एक एक्शन मैं आपको बताना चाहता
हूं मैंने आपको बता दिया तो अभी एक कम
करते हैं हम एक बार अपनी बैक तू स्क्रीन
पर चलते हैं तो कर लोग ना दोनों ये आप एक
वो खुद से ट्राई करके देख लो एक बार आप
सभी लोग बताना एक बार उसे ट्राई करके देख
लोग क्योंकि यार ऑलरेडी आई बिल क्लोज ओनली
644 तो वैसे ही हो गया लाइव क्लासेस में
भी टाइम तो कम मिलता है थोड़ा सा तो टाइम
मिलता है
भाई एक बार यस या नो
ओके ट्री करके ग्रुप में बता देना
वर्किंग और नोट वर्किंग तो एक कम करते हैं
फिर से हम एक बार अपने
चलो एक कम करते हैं
जो आपके बड़े में पता होना चाहिए जो भी
ट्विटर में अपने अभी तक शिखा है उसके समरी
में आपको याद दिल देता हूं एक बार तो शो
डेट की आप लोगों को पता नहीं देखो
वे हैव लर्नटी गुड ट्रिक इन ऑर्डर तू
रिवील और गदर इनफॉरमेशन अबाउट अवर टारगेट
ऑन ट्विटर यह आपको मैं आपको अच्छे से समझ
में ए गया होगी हमने कुछ ऐसी ट्रिक ट्रिक
सखी है जो ट्विटर ओपन सोशल टेलीविजन जो
आपको क्या कर रहे हैं काफी इनफॉरमेशन गदर
में आपको काफी हेल्प कर शक्ति है व्हेन
कैम्स तू हैकिंग वे नीड तू फॉक्स हैकिंग
इन जो अबाउट फॉक्सिंग और डोंट गेट
डिसएप्वॉइंटेड एजीली इसमें खाने का मतलब
ये है की देखो जब भी आप क्या कर रहे हो की
एथिकल हैकिंग के एक्टिविटी परफॉर्म कर रहे
हो तो आपका पूरा पूरा जो कम होता है
बॉक्सिंग होता है आपको फॉक्स करना होता है
किसी एक पार्टिकल चीज के ऊपर अगर आपका
फॉक्स भी कहता हूं आपको सबसे पहले आपको
फॉक्स ज्यादा स्ट्रांग करना होगा इस के
बेसिस पे आप क्या करते हो ज्यादा चीजों के
बड़े में एनालिसिस कर पाओगे ज्यादा से
ज्यादा चीजों के बड़े में पढ़ पाओगे
ज्यादा से ज्यादा चीजों के बड़े में एक
पाओगे
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग होती है जो भी होती है
तो आपको क्या करना जब भी वो कम कर रहे हो
तो आपको कभी भी डिसएप्वाइंट नहीं होना है
अगर कोई चीज आपको नहीं मिल रही है अगर आप
लिंक नहीं कर पाएं डोंट गेट डिसएप्वाइंट
आप क्या करना है जस्ट ट्राई और कप डूइंग
आपको ट्राई करना है और कंटिन्यू करते रहना
है जब तक आपको सक्सेस ना मिल जाए क्योंकि
हो सकता की आपको वह चीज एक दिन में समझ
में नहीं आए क्योंकि आप बेगिनेर हो सकता
है
की मैं आपको बताता हूं की वो चीज 10 दिन
के बाद आपको डेफिनेटली ऑटोमेटिक चीज आप
सोच रहे होंगे उसके बड़े में और आप जमीन
करने की कोशिश नहीं हो रही होगी तो 10-15
दिन के बाद आप कंटिन्यू सी चीज को फॉक्स
कर रहे हो ना तो अब क्या आपका ऑटोमेटिक
चीज समझ में आए जो की ये हो सकता है ये हो
सकता है तो चीज ऑटोमेटिक क्या है एक इमेज
क्रिएट होने ग जाएगा लिंक अपने आप ही होने
ग जाएंगे
सभी को पता है सबसे फर्स्ट स्टेज होती है
किसी भी हैकिंग के अंदर इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग
होती है इसलिए स्पेस सबसे ज्यादा टाइम
दिया जाता है अगर इसको भी टाइम नहीं डॉग
तो फिर आप पर्दे स्टेज में तो काफी
फ्रस्टेड होता है क्योंकि जितनी ज्यादा
आपके पास इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग होगी जितनी
ज्यादा आपको अपने टारगेट के बड़े में
इनफॉरमेशन होगी जितनी ज्यादा हो जो अमाउंट
में चाहे उसके फ्रेंड्स हो कोई भी अकाउंट
हो तो जो भी इनफॉरमेशन आपके पास जितनी
ज्यादा मंत्र में होंगे उतनी ज्यादा आप
क्या कर पाओगे किसी चीज पे फॉक्स कर पाओगे
कम कर पाओगे सिंपली मतलब ये है अब पर
एग्जांपल अभी आगे चलते चलो एग्जांपल बाद
में तो फॉक्स का मतलब क्या है की डोंट
बिलीव एनीथिंग इसी पे भी आपको क्या करना
है किसी भी चीज के ऊपर किसी भी फैक्ट के
ऊपर आपको क्या डायरेक्टली बिलीव नहीं करना
है आंख बैंड करके विश्वास नहीं करना है यू
हैव तू नोट व्हाट एवर यू फाइंड और ट्री तू
लिंक टुगेदर और
एवरीडे जस्ट रियली और एवरीडे जस्ट रीड
क्विकली बिफोर यू स्टार्ट पर डी स्टेप्स
वही डूइंग दिस यू कैन इजीली गैस व्हाट बिल
बी योर नेक्स्ट स्टेप्स देखो क्या है इसका
सिंपली मतलब फॉक्स से मेरा मतलब ये है की
किसी चीज पे आप विश्वास नहीं करना आपको
क्या करना है हर एक चीज को क्या करना है
की समझना है उनको लिंक करने की कोशिश करनी
है एक दूसरे के साथ उसके बाद पर एग्जांपल
आज आपने और ऑफ डी दे दो घंटे किसी के ऊपर
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग किया तो 2 घंटे में जो
भी इनफॉरमेशन कहते हैं आपने रेलीवेंट हो
ही रेलीवेंट हो हर एक चीज को नोट डॉ करके
रख लीजिए हर एक चीज को नोट डॉ करके लिख
दीजिए उसके बाद उनको क्या है
इंटरनेट पर स्पेंड किया उसके बाद
क्या-क्या उनको चीजों को समझो की ये कैसे
कलेक्ट कर दिया और उनको लिंक करने की
कोशिश करो तो चलो आज 2 घंटे में आप कुछ 1%
2% इनफॉरमेशन आप निकाल पे तो उसे कर घंटे
में जितने भी
जब नेक्स्ट आप क्या करोगे फिर से आप क्या
करते हो इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करने के लिए पर
डी स्टेप आपको वही फिर से वही करना चाहते
हो इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करनी है कंटिन्यू
क्योंकि आपके पास ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन नहीं
है तो पहले आप जो आपने नोट्स में आपके पास
रेलीवेंट इनफॉरमेशन थी या एरेलमेंट
इनफॉरमेशन थी वो साड़ी की साड़ी आपको क्या
करना है एक बार से फिर से एक बार देखना है
पढ़ना है आपके पास अभी प्रेजेंट में क्या
इनफॉरमेशन है फिर नेक्स्ट स्टेप बढ़ो की
आपने हो गया प्रीवियसली मैंने स्टेप
परफॉर्म कर चुका हूं अभी मुझे क्या करना
है क्योंकि अगर आप क्या करोगे जो भी आपने
नोट डॉ किया होगा वो एक बार को थ्रू कर
लोग तो आपके दिमाग में रहेगा की ये चीज
मेरे को पहले से पता है तो जब भी आप क्या
करते हो नेक्स्ट है परफॉर्म करने की कोशिश
करोगे डिटेल जाओगे या फिर से आप कहानी से
भी स्टार्ट करोगे तो आपके पास पहले से कुछ
इनफॉरमेशन है तो हर चीज को क्या करूं उसे
इनफॉरमेशन आप लिंक करने की कोशिश करोगे
उसे इनफॉरमेशन जोड़ने की कोशिश करोगे जब
आप लिंक करने की कोशिश करोगे तो आपके पास
पहले से कुछ इनफॉरमेशन तभी तो लिंक कर
पाओगे ना लिंक किसी चीज को एडरवाइज आप
लिंक ही नहीं कर पाओगे तो लिंक करने के
लिए आपके पास इनफॉरमेशन होना चाहिए और
इनफॉरमेशन आपके पास होता है एक बार आपको
को थ्रू करना ही पड़ेगा नेक्स्ट अगर आपके
पास जब एक चीज है की आपके पास से
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग के स्टेप कंप्लीट हो
गया अपने इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर ली एक
महीने तक इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग की किसी
टारगेट कंपनी का किसी को और आपके पास हो
सकता है की 10 15 पेज की ऐसी इनफॉरमेशन है
और उसमें से ये 10 15 पेज में से आप हो
सकता है की दो से तीन पेज एक इनफॉरमेशन है
की जो आप क्या कर पे एक दूसरे के साथ लिंक
कर पे चलो इतनी इनफॉरमेशन आपके पास है फिर
भी अगर आप उसके बाद नेक्स्ट स्टेप पे जा
रहे हो स्टैंडिंग है एन्यूमरेशन है उसके
बाद वैलिडिटी एनालिसिस है वो साड़ी चीज आप
जाओगे तो आपको क्या करना है फिर भी हम जान
से पहले डेली हर बार कोई भी स्टेप पे जा
रहे हो तो प्रीवियस स्टेप जितने भी किया
हैं उनको एक बार को थ्रू करो आधा घंटा 15
मिनट एक बार देखोगे आपके पास क्या
इनफॉरमेशन है और जब वो इनफॉरमेशन आपके पास
होगी तो आपके आपका मन सेट रहेगा आपके
दिमाग में वो इनफॉरमेशन याद रहेगी अगर वो
इनफॉरमेशन आपके पास में रहेगी और आपको याद
रहेगा तो क्या कर पाओगे क्योंकि नेक्स्ट
स्टेप में आपके पास अटैक
आसानी से आप ज्यादा बना पाओगे सोच पाओगे
किसी चीज को ट्राई करने बैठोगे तो आप
बोलोगे की यार मैं एक चीज एक इनफॉरमेशन
लिंक नहीं कर पाया था
क्या मैं उसे इनफॉरमेशन को यहां उसे कर
सकता हूं मैं हो सकता है की वो इनफॉरमेशन
जो उन लिंक थी वो यहां पर आपके ऐसे ही कम
ए जाए की लिंक इनफॉरमेशन उसे चीज को
एक्सप्लोरर पर अनलिंक इनफॉरमेशन हो उसको
एक्सप्लॉयड कर पे ये था आपका इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग का जस्ट एक ये तो किसके उधर
ट्विटर के थ्रू
ये था मेरी थोड़ी आप लोगों की किसके बड़े
में ट्विटर के बड़े में एक छोटा सा टॉपिक
है
15 मिनट लगेंगे कर कर लेते हैं आज ट्विटर
में खत्म नहीं करेंगे क्योंकि तीन दिन हो
चुके हैं आप लोग भी बर हो गए तो नेक्स्ट
हमारा ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस अप आता है
जिसको जो किसके थ्रू हम करेंगे लिंक दें
के थ्रू आज जो नेक्स्ट जो हमारा टॉपिक है
लिंक दें ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
अब लिंकडइन ओपन इंटेलिजेंस होता क्या है
लिंकडइन लिंकडइन सबको पता है कौन उसे करता
है और हम भी लिंकडइन आप लोगों से उसे
करवाते हैं ओके तो लिंकडइन पर हम क्या है
आज थोड़ा सा टारगेट बदलेंगे आज हम क्या
करें लिंकडइन के लिए हम अपना थोड़ा सा
टारगेट बदलेंगे देखो सबको पता है लिंकडइन
अलसो मोस्ट पॉपुलर प्लेटफॉर्म इंटेलिजेंस
ये भी मोस्ट पॉपुलर है क्यों क्योंकि जो
बिजनेस प्रोफेशनल है वो इसको उसे करते हैं
ट्विटर में तो ऐसा है की कुछ चीज आप
कोलगेट कर ही नहीं का रहे आप लिंक बनाई
नहीं का रहे और एक अकेला ट्विटर तो है
नहीं जिसके बेसिस पर एनालिसिस करके पूरा
इनफॉरमेशन टाइप कर सकते हो नो इनफॉरमेशन
करना है तो पूरा सोशल मीडिया आता है आप एक
ट्विटर के बेस पर हो ना पुरी इनफॉरमेशन को
वेरी कर पाओगे वेरीफाई कर पाओगे तो इसलिए
इंटेलिजेंस के द्वारा लेकिन आपके पास
इनफॉरमेशन है यहां पर क्या का सकते हैं उन
चीजों को आप लिंक भी कर पाओगे तो सबसे
पहले आपको क्या करना है जब भी आप
लिंकडइंटेलिजिबल कर सकते हो जितनी इसकी
पोस्ट पर सकते हो जितने इसमें उसके
क्योंकि इसमें पट्टी पर टारगेट के बड़े
में काफी डिटेल इनफॉरमेशन मिलती है पर
एग्जांपल अभी मैं आपको दिखता हूं चलो लाइव
भी चलते हैं
पर एग्जांपल अभी चलते हैं
तो यह मेरा लिंग दिन पहले
कम करते हैं अभी ओपन करते हैं
अभी मैं क्या कर रहा हूं की मेरे पास आई
यहां पर यहां पोस्ट पोस्ट क्या कर सकते हो
पोस्ट दाल सकते हो और यहां पर क्या है
सर्च कहां पर कर सकते हैं यहां पर यहां पर
आप ये सर्च का रहे हैं यहां पर सर्च कर
सकते हो पर एग्जांपल मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
दी आई एफ आर ओ एफ अपनी वेबसाइट पे मैं
कहना सब्सक्राइब
ठीक है यहां पर क्या देख सकते हो आप 245
इसके फॉलोअर हैं और इसको मैं क्या करता
हूं व्यू पेज मतलब मैं क्या डिप्रैस का
वेब पेज ओपन करना चाहता हूं लिंक दें पर
तो मैंने लिंक देने पर जो साइबर
सिक्योरिटी है उसका वेब पेज मैंने ओपन कर
लिया अब मैं यहां पर काफी इनफॉरमेशन देखो
यहां पर
इसके बड़े में पढ़ो क्या है इंडियास
लीडिंग साइबर सिक्योरिटी टेक्नोलॉजी
ट्रेनिंग सर्टिफिकेट ओके उसके बाद इसमें
245 इसके फॉलोअर हैं
इसके अंदर देखो इनफॉरमेशन मिलेगी अभी तक
हमारे पास अगर कोई भी पेटीएम कंपनी का भी
अगर मैं एग्जांपल लेट हूं उसके पास
इनफॉरमेशन नहीं थी लेकिन यहां पे 22 अगर
मैं अगर एग्जांपल दिखता हूं आपको
मैं क्रोम भी मेरे पास क्रोम में क्या
करता हूं ये भी मेरा लिंक देना है तो हम
अरे यार मैं तो पोस्ट
मैंने ओपन किया पेटीएम पेटीएम
प्ले इनफॉरमेशन देखते हो बाकी आपका ओ क्या
कर सकते हो मैं मोड में जाता हूं मोर में
क्या इनफॉरमेशन है मेरे को वैसे कुछ
रिक्वेस्ट नो सेंड इमेज ऑफ मैसेज कर सकते
हो उसके बाद क्या है होम में देखा हूं मैं
होम पेज में कुछ लिखा गया मुंबई में देखो
क्या क्या डिटेल है ओके ये डिटेल तो
वेबसाइट ये है इनकी ओके हम क्या करते हैं
इसको वेबसाइट को ओपन कर लेते हैं एजुकेशन
इंडस्ट्रीज
जो नहीं हनी चाहिए नॉर्मली वैसे दे राखी
है उसके बाद पोस्ट देखोगे अब पोस्ट में
ओके अबाउट में इनफॉरमेशन आपको मिल ही गई
क्या हां यह अबाउट इनफॉरमेशन थी अब पोस्ट
देखोगे पोस्ट से आप आइडिया लगाओगे क्या चल
रहा है देखो ये ओके चलो या कुछ कोई
ट्रेनिंग करवा रहे हैं ट्रेनिंग में
फर्स्ट के बाद यहां पर क्या लाइक देखोगे
कमेंट देखोगे तो यहां से आपको आइडिया मिल
जाएंगे तो लाइक फोन कर रहे हैं आप लाइफ
में कौन मिलेंगे या तो अभी ये ट्रेनिंग का
स्टूडेंट मिलेंगे और ये इतना डेफिनेटली
होता है की स्टूडेंट में कोई ना कोई तो
कंपनी का या तो कोई स्पोर्ट टीम हो गई कोई
टीम होगी या कोई ट्रेनर होगा जो इनको
रिप्लाई भी कर रहा होगा जो इनको रिप्लाई
भी करेगा ही करेगा क्यों क्यों नहीं प्ले
करेगा क्योंकि जरूरी होता है क्योंकि ये
रिप्लाई करेगा लाइक कमेंट क्योंकि तभी तो
इंटरेक्शन बनाने के लिए ना तो वो भी लाइक
कर रहा है इनको तो वहां से आपके पास
इनफॉरमेशन है की ये इनका कोई ना कोई
एम्पलाई हो सकता है या कोई रिसेप्शनिस्ट
हो सकता है या कोई भी हो सकता है तो अब ये
साड़ी पोस्ट पढ़ो अच्छा ये दूसरा कोर्स हो
सकता है डिलीवरी कर चुके हैं मैंने यहां
पर बहुत इनफॉरमेशन है अब यहां पर चेहरा
वेरिएबल है अब यहां पर क्योंकि हम थोड़ी
सी कंपनियां क्योंकि हम साइबर सिक्योरिटी
वाले तो हमें पता है हमें लिए कितनी
इन्फॉर्म सीकर कर सकते हैं तो अभी यहां पर
क्या जब में देख सकते हो क्या कोई जब ऑफर
करती है कंपनी तभी तक क्या है की कोई भी
ये क्या है कोई जब ऑफर नहीं कर रहे हैं अब
उसके बाद क्या पीपल में जाइए यहां देख
सकते हो यहां देख सकते हो वो एम्पलाई की
डिटेल यहां पर 22 एम्पलाई हैं तो कौन-कौन
सी एम्पलाई हैं अभी यहां पे देख कितना
अच्छे तरीके से दिया हुआ है 23 इंडिया है
भाई माफ महाराष्ट्र ये क्या इनफॉरमेशन है
वेद देवर लाइव ओके इंडिया महाराष्ट्र
हरियाणा ग्रेटर दिल्ली एरिया ये काफी
इनफॉरमेशन ये काफी अच्छी इनफॉरमेशन दी हुई
है यहां पर काफी कुछ ये शायद इसकी
इनफॉरमेशन दी है
ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके
और बिल्कुल सही इनफॉरमेशन है यहां पर चलो
देखो
यह देखो
यह राजकुमार मृत्यु
को जा के देख सकते हो हर एक पेज को विजिट
करके दे सकते हो कौन क्या एम्पलाई है का
क्या लोकेशन उसने दी है कोई एग्जांपल अभी
है वही तो क्या करता हूं रितेश सिंह को
देखा हूं तो अब यहां पे देख सकते हैं
फार्मूले हैं डिफाइनिंग साइबर सिक्योरिटी
एक्स को फाउंडर मटर सॉल्यूशन ओके तो अब
क्या कर सकते हो कंपनी के प्रोफाइल हमने
ओपन कर ली अब यहां पे हम क्या कर रहे हैं
इंडिविजुअल की प्रोफाइल भी ओपन करके दे
सकते हैं क्योंकि लिंकडइन में इसी तरीके
से इनफॉरमेशन मिलती है अभी इन्होंने क्या
दिया था अपनी बड़े में फाउंडर ने एक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एक्ट को फाउंडर मैट्रिक्स का
सॉल्यूशन क्रिएटर टेक्निकल नाम मतलब युटुब
है ये इनकी क्वालिफिकेशन है ओके तो अब मैं
क्या का सकता हूं देखो कंपनी के बड़े में
हमें अबाउट में जितनी इनफॉरमेशन मिली
हमारे पास वेबसाइट मिलेगी ये इनकी वेबसाइट
हमें वेबसाइट मिलेगी अब वेबसाइट पे भी हम
देख सकते हैं क्या इनफॉरमेशन है वो हम देख
सकते हैं अभी क्या है हमारे पास क्या है
अब ये फाउंडर है मतलब सी ए ओ है हमारे पास
ये इनफॉरमेशन है अभी देखो मैं क्या करता
हूं इन्होंने अपनी लोकेशन यहां पर बता
राखी मैं पटना बिहार से बिलॉन्ग करता हूं
चलो इन्होंने अपनी क्या लोकेशन भी एक्सपोज
कर दी उसके बाद कांटेक्ट इनफॉरमेशन करता
हूं मैं कांटेक्ट इनफॉरमेशन करता हूं
देखिए इन्होंने क्या किया इनफॉरमेशन दिया
आपको लिंकडइन प्रोफाइल दे रही है वेबसाइट
ब्लॉक वेबसाइट ओके युटुब अदर उसके बाद
एड्रेस पटना दे रखलो इन्होंने क्या कहते
हैं आप अपने ईमेल एड्रेस भी दे राखी है
इन्होंने अपनी ईमेल एड्रेस दे राखी है
उसके बाद उन्होंने अपना बर्थ दे तक यहां
पर दिया हुआ है अभी देखो क्या है की
लिंकडइन में क्या होता है की अभी एक चीज
बताता हूं आपको लिंक देने में देखो यहां
पर क्या ए रहा है आपको देखने को इनका नाम
नितेश सिंह ब्रैकेट में टेक्निकल
एवरग्रीगेटर आपको क्या लगता है की ये जो
नाम होगा इसका आपको क्या लगता है की क्या
ये इस प्रोफाइल का यूजरनेम होगा
इस प्रोफाइल का क्या ये यूजरनेम होगा आप
लोगों को क्या लगता है यस या नो या ये
यूजर नाम
बताइए
यस या नो
नो आप लोग
क्या हो सकता है की जो भी यूजर्स है
लिंकडइन प्रोफाइल जिसकी उसने यहां पर अलग
यूजर नाम दिया हुआ लेकिन क्या की जी
वीडियो नाम से प्रोफाइल चल रही है हमेशा
देखने यहां पर ध्यान देना है यहां पे देखो
लिंकडइन यहां पर देखो इसके बाद जो देखने
को मिल रहा है ना ये उसे नाम है एक्चुअल
में ये इसका यूजरनेम है इस प्रोफाइल का तो
यूजर नाम आपको देखने को कहां पर मिल रहा
है यहां पर किसी भी उसका देखना चाहे
फेसबुक हो ट्विटर हो इंस्टाग्राम हो सबका
उसे नाम आपको यही पे मिलेगा यू आर ल में
जो सही यूजरनेम उसे हो रहा है इस आईडी के
लिए इस आईडी के लिए
तो इस तरीके से आप यहां पर क्या इनफॉरमेशन
देख सकते हो देखो लिंकन में क्या-क्या
इनफॉरमेशन देख सकते हो अगर कंपनी का वायर
पेज है उससे आप दे सकते हो की उसकी
एम्पलाई की डिटेल उसमें क्या-क्या
प्रोजेक्ट चल रहे हैं किस किस टाइप के वो
कंपनी है क्योंकि प्रोजेक्ट आप उससे पता
कर सकते क्योंकि कंपनी कुछ ना कुछ शेर कर
रही होगी उसके कांटेक्ट इनफॉरमेशन देख
सकते हो अब कंपनी के हम इतनी मिलेगी
क्योंकि अगर आपको पास कंपनी के बाद
एम्पलाई की डीटेल्स मिल रही है आगे कंपनी
के पेज से फिर आप फरदर क्या करोगे क्योंकि
कंपनी के बड़े में मुझे नहीं इनफॉरमेशन
मिल रही है उसके बाद क्या करोगे आप जाओगे
पीपल के ऊपर वहां पुचके एम्पलाई के बाद
एम्पलाई में से क्या करोगे सारे एम्पलाई
मिलेंगे मैक्सिमम एंपलॉयर मैक्सिमम
एम्पलाई भी मिलेंगे प्रेजेंट एम्पलाई भी
मिलेंगे तो आप क्या करोगे हर एक एम्पलाई
को मैक्सिमम क्या कर रहे हो आप बड़े-बड़े
एम्पलाई को या आपको ऐसा लगता है की कोई
ज्यादा टंकी एम्पलाई लगता है तो डोंट टच
आईटी हो सकता है कोई अगर थ्रेड हंटर है या
साइबर सिक्योरिटी ज्यादा प्रोफेसर एंपलॉयर
कर दे उसके प्रोफाइल से लगता है तो उसको
थोड़ा टाइम के लिए स्किप करो लेकिन टारगेट
लिस्ट में रखो उसके अलावा फिर नॉर्मल जो
नॉर्मल आईडी में एचआरडी डिपार्मेंट वो
डिपार्मेंट वो एम्पलाई आपको देखने को
मिलते हैं तो आपके लिए वो इजी टारगेट हो
सकते हैं आपके लिए वो ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन के
अंदर कर सकते हैं क्योंकि उनको इतनी
सिक्योरिटी के बड़े में नॉलेज नहीं रहती
जितना आपको क्या है की जो टेक्निकल बंदे
को राहत है तो फिर इस टाइप के क्या करोगे
आप वो एम्पलाई को वन बाय वन बाय उसकी
प्रोफाइल चेक करोगे अब ये 22 एम्पलाई तो
22 की एम्पलाई किया प्रोफाइल चेक कर सकते
हो उसके बाद किसी भी प्रोफाइल पर आओगे तो
क्या क्या चेक कर सकते हो यह चेक कर सकते
हो की उसका यूजर नाम क्या एक्चुअल में ये
यूजरनेम हो सकता है ये यूजर नाम क्या है
की इसका रियल यूजर नाम हो या फेक भी हो
सकता है जय इन्होंने क्या है रियल नाम
यहां उसे किया है लेकिन इस प्रोफाइल के
लिए उसे नाम उसे किया और गूगल सर्च करके
आप यूजरनेम के बेसिस पे पता कर सकते हैं
की क्या इस पर्टिकुलर नाम से और भी कोई
सोशल मीडिया प्लेटफॉर्म है या सोशल मीडिया
हैंडल पे ये कम करते हैं उनकी कोई आईडी है
वो आप पता कर सकते हो कैसे कर सकते हो पर
एग्जांपल मैं क्या करता था जरा मैंने ओपन
किया इसको
कॉपी और मे इसको क्या करता हूं टेस्ट
कर देता हूं
एक तो वेबसाइट देखने को मिल रही है और
मुझे क्या देखने को मिल रहा है युटुब पे
देखने मिल रहा है इंस्टाग्राम भी यही
देखने को मिल रहा है
लिंडे मिली रहा है उसके बाद और क्या देखना
है फेसबुक भी इसी पर मिल देखने को मिल रहा
है और बता देखो इस नाम से और भी टेलीग्राम
इसी से देखने को मिल रहा है बल्कि
निदेशारे मिल नहीं रहा तो हो सकता की नीति
सिंह आपने उसे किया हो तो उसके बाद वो
इनफॉरमेशन ज्यादा देखने को ना मिले लेकिन
आपने टेक्निकल एवरीडे से उसे किया क्योंकि
ये पॉपुलर है क्योंकि इसी के बेस पर आईडी
बनी हुई है तो ये देखना है अब यहां पे और
क्या इनफॉरमेशन है कांटेक्ट में जाओगे
कांटेक्ट में जान के बाद क्या सकते हो की
क्या इनकी कोई खुद की वेबसाइट तो नहीं है
या इनका एड्रेस ईमेल बर्थडे बर्थडे के
बेसिस भी है क्योंकि बर्थडे भी तो काफी
हेल्प कर सकता है उसके बाद क्या है की ये
अपनी प्रोफाइल में कोई ना कोई ऐसी पोस्ट
दाल रहे होंगे जो आपके कम हो उसके बाद
यहां पर क्या है की हो सकता है की बिजनेस
ईमेल के अलावा नॉर्मल ईमेल अब इन्होंने
क्या खुद की ईमेल डाली हुई है उसके बाद
बिजनेस ईमेल मिल शक्ति है वनडे में मिल
गया मोबाइल नंबर मोबाइल नंबर मिल सकता है
तो यहां पर इनकी इतनी साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिल रही है और क्या देखने मिल
रहा है प्रेजेंट का उसके बाद वो नीचे चलते
हैं हर एक इंडिविजुअल प्रोफाइल के बड़े
में पता कर सकते हो ऐसे मैं सिर्फ एक
एग्जांपल दिखा रहा हूं अब यह देखो यह
पोस्ट और कमेंट बताओ
इनका एक्सपीरियंस
सॉल्यूशन के कंटेंट क्रिएटर टेक्निकल
लिमिट युटुब चैनल ये इनका एक्सपीरियंस है
ओके उसके बाद क्या एजुकेशन क्या है
राजस्थान टेक्निकल यूनिवर्सिटी से पढ़े
हुए हैं बीटेक कंप्यूटर साइंस इंजीनियरिंग
ओके उसके बाद क्या है टेन प्लस तू साइंस
मठ कहां से की की बीजेपी
कब की 2011 से 2012 में
2016 में इन्होंने किया है ये एक
ग्रेजुएशन उसके बाद 10 स्टैंडर्ड का इतनी
साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन खुद से दी हुई है उसके
बाद क्या है लाइसेंस नोटिफिकेशन करके
उसके बेसिक क्या कर सकते हो आप ईमेल और
सेंड कर सकते हो यूजरनेम वो सेंड कर सकते
हैं पॉसिबल है नहीं तो मैं सबसे बड़ा तो
अटैक यही है की होता है की सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग पर हो गया आप उसके बेस पर
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग करोगे फिर साड़ी
इनफॉरमेशन आपको ट्विटर पे वो इनफॉरमेशन
नहीं मिली ट्विटर पे आप प्रोफाइल्स को
लिंक नहीं कर पे बट यहां पर आपको
प्रोफाइल्स के लिंक मिल गए पर इनको ट्विटर
ट्विटर पे भी क्या कर सकते हो उसे कर सकते
हो यहां एक कम करो आप सबसे पहले लिंक दें
और सेंड करो उसके बाद ट्विटर और सेंड करो
लिंक दें की इनफॉरमेशन ज्यादा अच्छी आई है
तो उसको क्या करो उसे इनफॉरमेशन के साथ
कंपेयर करो तो आपकी क्या है की जो
इनफॉरमेशन का देंगे स्केल क्या है थोड़ी
सी और स्ट्रांग होगी आपके पास लिंक अच्छे
होंगे तो इस तरीके से क्या कर सकते हैं
इसी भी टारगेट के बड़े में ज्यादा से
ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन निकाल सकते हो और ऐसे ही
आप चीजों को लिंक कर पाओगे और जब मैं बात
किया थे ना की सोशल मीडिया जो ओपन सोर्सेस
होता है तो कुछ भी निकाल सकता है की भैया
उसके लायक उसकी डिसलाइक उसकी फीलींगस उसको
क्या चीज अच्छी लगती है क्या चीज अच्छी
नहीं लगती क्या उसकी फेवरेट है क्या
फेवरेट नहीं है उसके मोबाइल नंबर उसके
ईमेल उसके जीमेल बिजनेस ईमेल और वह कैसा
दिखता है वह साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन क्या है की
वह आप क्या कर सकते हो सोशल मीडिया ओपन
सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस से निकाल सकते हो उसके
बाद फरदर आपके पास ऑप्शन होते हैं की आपको
आपके आप अटैक सरफेस रेडी करने होते हैं
अटैक सर्फेस में आप कितने टाइप का टैग कर
सकता हूं उसके बाद आप सोशल मीडिया वो सो
सॉरी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का नहीं सोचोगे
कहानी कोई फिशिंग करने की सोचोगे क्योंकि
फिशिंग करने के लिए आपको ईमेल चाहिए होगी
तो यह साड़ी चीज आप क्या करोगे लिंक दें
से इतने टाइम इनफॉरमेशन निकाल सकते हैं ये
तो मैं सिर्फ एक इनकी इनफॉरमेशन निकाल के
दिखाए पर एग्जांपल मैं बैक जाता हूं तो
अभी मैं बैक करता हूं और अभी बैक
चलो
आपके लिए ठीक है डीसी एस पी बी सी एस
सिक्योरिटी सिटी है ओके है एकदम
सिक्योरिटी से अब इनके बड़े में और
ज्यादातर कांटेक्ट इनफॉरमेशन
के टेक्निकल टेक्नोलॉजी ऑफिसर
यहां से ले सकते हो आप अब आपके पास ईमेल
होगी इनकी पर्सनल ईमेल होगी और मोबाइल
नंबर हो गया तो उसके बेसिस पे आगे जा सकते
हो कनेक्शन चेक कर सकते हो क्या क्या मतलब
बहुत कुछ आप इनफॉरमेशन देख सकते हो इनके
बड़े में भी तो इस तरीके से आप क्या होती
है की इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग की जाति है और एक
और चीज बताता हूं की जब भी ये कम करोगे आप
कभी भी देखना की किसी भी एक प्रोफाइल का
आप ओपन करते हो जैसे मैंने हार्दिक
असली बाल की जो मैंने प्रोफाइल को ओपन
किया है सॉरी पर डेट अगर मैं आपका
प्रनंसीएशन गलत कर का रहा हूं तो अगेन की
प्रोफाइल को मैंने ओपन किया है एक बात
देखिए की हमें साइड में जो ये रहा इस पैनल
में पीपल अलसो व्यूज में जो आपको सजेस्ट
करेगा ना वो सजेस्ट करेगा जो इसके
फॉलोअर्स रहे होंगे या इनके दोस्त रहेंगे
इनको फॉलो करते हैं या इनके दोस्त हो सकते
हैं तो इसे भी आप आइडिया लगा सकते हो के
जो यहां पर जो ए रहे हैं बेवजह नहीं ए रहे
हैं वो आपके नहीं ए रहे हैं वो जो
प्रोफाइल आपके सामने खली हुई है उन्हें के
यहां पर फॉलोअर्स हैं या उन्हें के उन्हें
के क्या है दोस्त लोग यहां पर या दोस्त
देखने को मिल रहे हैं यहां पे देखो सारे
सारे इन्हीं से रिलेटेड मिलेंगे जो इनके
कांटेक्ट लिस्ट में तो फिर फरदर क्या कर
सकते हो इनको हो सकता है की अगर हार्दिक
जी हैं जो हमारे अगर वो कंप्रोमाइज नहीं
कर का रहे किसी भी करण बस से डोंट वारी
इसे थोड़ा सा वीक इनमें मिल जाएगा इस
लिस्ट में मिल जाएगा तो यहां से इसको आप
देखोगे उसको मैच करके देखो ओके ये इसकी
फॉलिंग लिस्ट में है क्या ये इस कंपनी के
लिए कम करता नहीं करता ओके इसका मतलब
फ्रेंड है क्लोज फ्रेंड हो सकता है तो ये
कोई इनफॉरमेशन नहीं रिवील कर रहा होगा तो
आप इसको अपना टारगेट बनोगे इस टारगेट से
दूसरे टारगेट स्किप करोगे फिर आप कंपनी तक
पहुंचोगे तो इस तरीके से क्या किया जाते
हैं इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग स्टेप की परफॉर्म
किया जाते हैं तो ये था आपका लिंक दें सो
इंटेलिजेंस लिंकडइन में कुछ भी नहीं है बस
लिंकडइन में यही है लेकिन लिंकडइन काफी
हेल्प करता है आपको इनफॉरमेशन गैरेज में
क्योंकि लिंकडइन के पास जितनी होती है
साड़ी की साड़ी स्ट्रांग इनफॉरमेशन होती
है क्योंकि जितनी भी हम इनफॉरमेशन अच्छी
साड़ी की साड़ी स्ट्रांग इनफॉरमेशन देखनी
है अगर मैं आपको दिखता हूं क्रोम के ऊपर
भी तो क्रोम में देखोगे लिंक दिन मैंने
यहां पर तो आपको देखने को मिलेगा जूनियर
मैनेजर नो टीम सॉफ्टवेयर इंजीनियर एट
पेटीएम यहां पे तो बहुत इनफॉरमेशन देगा
क्या आपको वहां पर तो मिले भी नहीं था
सॉफ्टवेयर इंजीनियर पेटीएम दिल्ली इंडिया
चंडीगढ़ इंडिया पंजाब इंडिया इन्होंने तो
सब कुछ आपको खोल के दे दिया की भैया मैं
यहां राहत हूं मैं यहां राहत हूं इन्होंने
तो सब कुछ आपके सामने
सीनरी क्वालिटी एश्योरेंस इंजीनियर एट
पेटीएम जूनियर मैनेजर पेटीएम ओके
उत्तर प्रदेश इंडिया इसको मैं ओपन करता
हूं चलो यू कैन
लिमिटेड विजिबिलिटी ओके क्योंकि मैं
मेंबर्स भी नहीं होता उसके बाद चलो देख
लेते हैं जूनियर में जो करके
देखते हैं
जूनियर मैनेजर मार्केटिंग डिजाइन पेटीएम
चलो
और काफी है पेटीएम का एक्सपीरियंस है
दुनिया में टीम लीड है उसके ग्राफिक
डिजाइन है ये इनके एजुकेशन ये है ये है और
कहां से पड़े हुए हैं
है और यह
अपनी स्किल यहां पर मेंशन की हुई है
इनफॉरमेशन मिलती है
ओके
सामने किया है शो किया है बट एक चीज देखना
की आपको मैं कुछ मेरे को क्या कुछ मेरे
पास प्लगिंस है कुछ प्लगिंस है जो आपको
उसे करना सिखाऊंगा की पेटीएम के इसके जो
लिंक देना है लिंकडइन के साथ दो-तीन
प्लगिंस होते हैं वो काफी अच्छे कम करते
हैं की कुछ ऐसी इनफॉरमेशन होती है जो राहु
जी ने हमें यहां पर शो नहीं कर रहा हूं की
लेकिन वो कुछ प्लगिंस से वो क्या करते हैं
उसको एक्सपोज कर देते हैं तो जो नेक्स्ट
टॉपिक
से ईमेल इल्यूमिनेशन करेंगे और सॉरी ईमेल
ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस करेंगे और थोड़ी सी
और जनरल ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस करेंगे तो
उसमें क्या करेंगे वो प्लगिंस में बता
देता हूं वैसे अगर आप चाहे तो अगेंस्ट
एक्सटेंशन एड कर सकते हो तो अगर आप अभी तो
रहने दो सही टाइम नहीं है क्योंकि हर एक
प्लगइन को आप रजिस्टर करना पड़ेगा नहीं तो
आप क्या एक कम करो मैं आपको लिस्ट दे देता
हूं ये रहा आप क्या करो सबसे पहले प्लगइन
होता है चलो मैं बाद में करवाता हूं सारे
प्लगइन साथ के साथ बताता हूं वो आपको एक
चीज है की जितने प्लगइन से सारे रजिस्टर
करने पढ़ेंगे प्यार से पांच तीन से कर
प्लगइन के साथ स्पेशली कम करते हैं वो
इनफॉरमेशन देते हैं अगर मैं आपको डेमो
दिखाऊं राहुल जी को ये एक्सपोज करने की ये
रहा लेकिन मेरा कांटेक्ट कांटेक्ट
आउट करके प्लगइन है अगर आप देख सकते हो
देखो ये यहां पर कोई इनफॉरमेशन नहीं देखने
को मिल देखना देखो यहां पर मैं कम करता
हूं व्यू व्यू ईमेल देखो दो-दो ईमेल
एक्सपोज हुई है राहुल रोड
सक्सेना@paytm.com और ये रहा
ये रहा सक्सेना राहुल 3011 जीमेल दोनों
दोनों ही चीज मोबाइल नंबर क्या मैं देख का
रहा हूं अगर ओके मोबाइल नंबर नहीं हमारे
पास लेकिन देखो ये दो ईमेल एड्रेस आपके
सामने यहां पे मिल गए इन्होंने आपको शो कर
दिया जबकि ये यहां पर आपको देखने को नहीं
मिल रहा था अब ये फरदर चीज हम क्या कर
सकते हैं इनके बेसिस पे भी क्या कर सकते
हैं इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हैं
अगर पॉसिबल हुआ तो ये साड़ी चीज आप ऐसे
पता कर सकते हो और भी कुछ है यहां पर जैसे
की ये क्या है हमारा ये भी एक बार प्लगइन
है यहां पर कुछ इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिलती
है चलो ये देखते हैं
इनफॉरमेशन नहीं है
गेट पोस्ट गेट प्रोस्पेक्ट
जूनियर मैनेजर
चलो इसके बाद कोई इनफॉरमेशन नहीं है
उसके बाद
इनफॉरमेशन दे रहा है शायद
दिल्ली इंडिया जूनियर पेटीएम
8 वर्ष एक्सपीरियंस ओके एक्सपीरियंस मेंशन
किया है और भी क्या देखने को मिलती है
प्रोफाइल है
क एक्सपीरियंस
के बाद पता चला आपके नेक्स्ट क्लास के लिए
कम ही ना करें
हम क्या करते हैं आई बिल ट्राई तू पहले
फेसबुक
डेमो और उसके बाद क्या करते हैं थोड़ा सा
और इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग में थोड़ा स्टेप
परफॉर्म करने की कोशिश करते हैं ईमेल और
सेंड हो गया
थोड़ा फोन की और सेंट होगी उसके बाद हम एक
कम करें
डोंट वारी अगर जो आपका नंबर अपडेट 10 से
ऊपर जाएगा
पांच मिनट में अपने डाउट पूछ सकते हैं
हमसे
किसी का भी कोई भी डाउट है तो मुझे पूछ
सकता है
इसलिए कोई भी डाउट है कोई भी
अगर नहीं तो फिर
नो बता दीजिए प्लीज
यस या नो
चलो फिर किसी का कोई जवाब नहीं ठंड करते
हैं ओके बाय बाय
टेक केयर
एक और चीज है की आपका नेक्स्ट सेशन काली
होगा